bonjour à tous le constructeur chinois
qiao mu va arriver en france très
prochainement
et ça va changer pas mal de choses pour
vous donc s'envole regardez vous
expliquer ce qui va se passer en gros
grande attente les grandes nouveautés
tout ce qu'on a tous ce qui va arriver
est ce que ça va changer pour nous et ça
on y va maintenant
[Musique]
sheholli c'est un constructeur qui est
très connue de tous les amoureux
smartphone heures pas forcément encore
tout le monde
beaucoup de personnes qui veulent des
produits de très bonne qualité pas très
chers sont tournés du côté de chez eux
mais du côté de la chine alors
effectivement en chine y'a pas de chez
tommy bowe être plus au nord revoyez
compagnie et puis plein d'autres mais
xiaomi en tout cas une très bonne
réputation pour avoir des produits
d'excellente qualité à des tarifs
défiant toute concurrence alors jusqu'à
maintenant pour avoir des productions me
fallait passer par des sites
importateurs à partir du mois de mai
très prochainement vous allez voir vous
n'aurez plus besoin de passer par des
importateurs vous pourrez acheter
directement à xiaomi en france et par
différentes façons différentes méthodes
qu'on appelle différents canaux je suis
obligé pas si vous avez vraiment fait
attention mais enfin quand ce ne sont
pas que des smartphones
il ya aussi des tablettes des pc des
drones des aspirateurs des lampes
il ya une gamme qui est extrêmement
complet tout simplement parce que en
réalité shiomi son coeur de métier c'est
le smartphone l'idée quand ils ont créé
la marque c'est de se dire on va créer
des smartphones haut de gamme d'une
excellente qualité mais des tarifs hyper
ma c'est vraiment leur adn et c'est
vraiment là dessus qu'ils sont vraiment
les meilleurs mais au-delà de ça shlomi
un cube
d'une certaine manière des start-up les
aide à se développer et mettre les
moyens en place et une fois que la start
up par un produit que je suis au 8e trou
en tout cas suffisamment intéressant
pour le mettre sur le marché
eh bien il le commercialise sous la
marque xiaomi ce qui fait que vous avez
toute une multitude de produits ça va
lui la lampe vous le dit l'aspirateur
pas mal de choses et shiro miss une
marque va continuer à se développer et à
gagner du terrain alors pour l'instant
en france on parle pas encore d'avoir
des lampes ou des pc des aspirateurs
d'été ou compagnie schumi pour l'instant
on est sur les smartphones j'ai la
chance d'avoir rencontré directement des
gens de l'équipe de chez eux au mit au
mois de février dernier au mwc à
barcelone et je puis vous assurer qu'ils
étaient un petit peu curieux quand ils
voyaient arriver en france est à vous
êtes français étonné de lima votre carte
je vous laisse ma carte recontactera
probablement ultérieurement
on voyait déjà en tout cas à ce moment
là la volonté shiomi d'arriver sur le
marché français et de commencer à
prendre un petit peu des contacts à
droite à gauche
à ce moment-là y venaient
ouvrir une boutique en espagne ils ont
déjà depuis quelques mois à l'expérience
du marché européen à travers l'espagne
et ça va continuer ça va faire des
petits encore parce que qu'est-ce qu'ils
aient aujourd'hui il joue pour shiomi
le développement sur le marché européen
l'espagne la france et après on imagine
tout le reste du territoire européen
pour avancer et gagner en parts de
marché c'est une vraie stratégie de
conquête face à un marché qui se
développe de plus en plus on m'a
expliqué un petit peu en europe on
m'avait confié que le curseur pour les
marques chinoises s'étaient huawei dès
lors que huawei atteignez les 10% de
parts marché dans un pays
les autres constructeurs chinois arrivé
derrière ça voulait dire que le marché
est mûr qu'il y a un vrai intérêt en
tout cas pour le pays pour aller vers
des produits chinois
d'où l'arrivée de shlomi et de tous les
autres qui vont arriver d'ici très peu
de temps comment est ce qu'on pouvoir
acheter ces produits chez au mit alors
dans un premier temps on va pouvoir les
acheter directement via leur site
traduit en version française donc au
lieu de passer par an revendeurs en
importateurs vous aurez directement un
produit chahoumi en mode français parce
qu'en plus ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que lorsque vous importez un smartphone
il faut l'acheter dans la global vers
sean la version globale pourrait faire
pour faire en français pour qu'il soit
compatible avec nos bandes à nous si
vous achetez un produit xiaomi
uniquement réservée au marché chinois
vous n'aurez pas les bandes française et
du coup vous pourrez vraiment faire mise
à part aller sur internet ne pourrait
pas du tout connecté au réseau gêner
celle ça ça quand même relativement
dommage donc du coup à ce qui est super
intéressant c'est qu'en achetant
directement sur le site de chiots me
dédier à la france vous allez acheter
les produits 100% compatible
complètement traduit en français et en
plus le truc qui va être complètement
top c'est que si quelques temps ils vont
ouvrir des magasins en france vous allez
avoir les mystères qui vont plus à
droite à gauche
pour l'instant on n'a pas de lieu de
confirmer ce qui est sûr c'est que rien
qui va sortir en tout premier à paris et
on verra ensuite le développement dans
le reste de l'hexagone d'ailleurs le 22
mai prochain ils vont tenir une
conférence de presse pour donner
justement leur stratégie de déploiement
donc on en saura davantage
restez connectés abonnez-vous parce que
dès qu'ils auront les infos je vais tout
vous dire autre chose qui est vraiment
super intéressant c'est qu'en achetant
directement sur le site de chez au mieux
leurs dons leur mise store vous allez
bénéficier d'un sav
directement auprès du constructeur et
pas uniquement auprès du revendeur donc
ce qui fait qu'en cas de pépin
vous pourrez les contacts et très
facilement et avec les histoires vous
aurez une vraie proximité pour pouvoir
aller les voir enfin proximité tout est
relatif à effectivement si une boutique
à paris une à lyon une à marseille on ne
peut pas forcément s'il rend très
facilement si on n'habite pas à
proximité de ces agglomérations là alors
au final qu'est ce que ça change
concrètement pour le consommateur c'est
ce que je vous disais déjà plus besoin
de passer par les revendeurs je citerai
directement auprès de l'ohmi le sav le
fn ça c'est vraiment point hyper fort le
sav j'irai directement par la marque des
produits 100% compatible avec les
banques françaises est un autre point
qui est vraiment très intéressant c'est
que ça va continuer à contribuer à faire
baisser les prix des smartphones parce
que le taux de renouvellement des
smartphones augmente les gens achètent
de moins en moins régulièrement de
smartphones ça coûte très cher avec des
tarifs qui augmente tout le temps du
côté de chez apple
du côté de samsung et même du côté de
chez huawei ça permet de libérer un
créneau pour les constructeurs chinois
qui arrivent avec des smartphones un peu
moins cher et avec vraiment des produits
d'excellente qualité
c'est le cas de chez home is est
vraiment là dessus qu'ils vont se mettre
dans cette brèche cela on le voit de
toute façon du côté de chez apple cette
année les tarifs devraient baisser pas
forcément sur les produits anciens mais
sur les produits neufs
on devrait avoir une gamme un peu plus
complète on va en parler très bientôt
donc
abonnez-vous en plus de ça va y avoir
une communauté qui va se développer si
vous allez sur la page facebook de
xiaomi france vous allez voir qu'ils
sont vraiment en train de parler à leurs
futurs clients à leurs clients déjà
actuels qui n'ont pas acheté chez eux
mais ils ont déjà un client de la maison
il ya vraiment un vrai sens de la
communication il ya des concours pour
gagner des smartphones chaulieu pas ya
vraiment quelque chose est en train de
se mettre en place va y avoir aussi des
forums dédiés pour que les consommateurs
puissent parler entre eux puisse parler
directement auprès de l'ohmi faire
remonter les infos un petit peu comme on
voit un engagement au niveau de la
communauté au niveau de one plus a
priori schumi devrait faire sensiblement
la même chose pour fidéliser et pour
avoir une image de proximité avec ses
clients
à noter que dès le 3 mai schumi va
lancer l'ami community est justement dès
le 3 mai
me community va être lancée par shiomi
vous êtes à surveiller sa très près si
vous vous intéressez effectivement un
chiot oui parce que vous allez voir
qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de choses qui
vont se faire et notamment au début au
lancement pour maximiser l'intérêt
autour de l'arrivée de survie en france
bon par contre pour l'instant on n'a pas
d'info sur les produits qui vont être
commercialisés quel produit il va être
commercialisé au niveau des smartphones
j'ai pu tester leurs ennemis 5 + a pas
très longtemps le mx2 aussi que j'ai pu
voir directement au mwc ya le mx2 est ce
qui a été annoncé il ya le mx3 qu'il
devrait arriver cette année ya pas mal
de nouveaux smartphones qu'ils vont
arriver
lesquels vont être commercialisés en
france j'imagine très clairement comme
unique de s devraient être présents si
la gamme réduit aussi fait pas mal de
produits phares de xiaomi donc on reste
connectés parce qu'on en reparle est
hyper rapidement une info qui nous vient
du journal du geek
a priori les pc portables et les télés
chifoumi n'arriverait pas pour le moment
et pas deux ne profite d'ailleurs
n'arriverait pas tout de suite
ou prenons l'exemple des télé par
exemple parce que l'interface n'est pas
encore prête n'a pas encore été traduite
en français donc on imagine tout et ils
vont arriver vraiment fort sur leur
coeur de métier sur le smartphone et
ensuite tout doucement ils vont arriver
dans leur mister avec plein de produits
et d'ici quelques mois avoir d'ici un an
on devrait avoir une offre à 360° made
in show me dites moi ce que vous en
pensez est ce que ça pourrait vous
intéresser tous ces nouveaux produits
survie ce que vous trouvez ça sexy est
ce que vous avez là est ce que vous
aimez la marque
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
produits chez tommy est ce que vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter est ce que
vous êtes déjà chez un constructeur
chinois
ce soit au nord ou à louer au pot ou en
plus et que ça j'ai encore mark et moi
tout ça en commentaire on reste
connectés parce que fondamentalement il
ya plein de choses poule qui va se
passer d'ici quelques temps vous invite
à le laisser des jolies pouces a marqué
tous vos commentaires avis suggestions
question et tout ce que vous voulez en
bas afin que tout le monde puisse
échanger là dessus merci à vous d'être
toujours plus nombreux de râler cette
vidéo donne rendez vous très rapidement
parce que vous allez voir les choses
hyper cool qui vont arriver merci soyez
sages à tréméreuc vous embrasse ciao
[Musique]